and on the hill for the yankees their
number one pitching prospect making his
first major league start
clark schmidt two down
and aguilar will be the batter
and aguilar swings and it lifts a drive
to deep right center cutting over his
hicks to make the catch and clark
schmidt has a very easy
one two three
jose uranya will take the mound for the
marlins and although it really won't
matter when it's all said and done a win
sure would feel nice to cap off the
season with 31 victories that'll bring
geo urchella to the plate
and second and third for the yankees no
score in the first here's the pitch
herchella hits it on the ground and it's
bobbled momentarily by jazz chisholm the
throw pulls aguilar off the bag but he's
able to tag her shella going by
six to three for the out that was shaky
marlins have two one and one out and
jazz chisholm coming up
and now jazz with a shot out to right
center field hicks turns around he'll
play it off the wall that'll score two
easily jazz chisholm in the second with
a stand-up double oh
my goodness young man
well here's corey dickerson the lead
outfitter with first and third two out
chew in
dickerson up the middle of base hit
that'll score jazz
an rbi single for corey dickerson and
the marlins put three runs on the board
here in the second eighth batter of the
inning starling martay coming up here's
the pitch
up and in and that took the helmet of
martay off and he's down on a knee
i think fortunately oh it got the brim
of the hell oh my goodness
probably a little bit stunned
but there's no reason to keep him in
this game at this point and it's pretty
simple to figure out three in three on
and two out
so that's eight and here's the ninth
hitter aguilar here's the two one hit on
the ground toward the middle fielded by
wade he throws to first in time and that
ends the inning so aguilar rounds out
four three
now here's le mayhew and dj walked his
first time
oh that hits urania and he goes down
and lemay was going to reach first and
let's see if ahrania is okay wow and
uranium writhing in pain on the ground
let's see exactly where it got him
like his pitching hand
goodness the last day of the season
voight d h is today he's been playing on
a bad foot and the yankees have been
very mum about the extent of the injury
on 2-1 voight bounces one through the
legs of castano out behind second bird
he's got it onto first and castano
sneaks out of the inning
so voigt bounces out 4-3 on the ball
back up the middle
here's gary sanchez the catcher
with torres at first two outs marlins
leading three nothing bottom of the
fourth
two one to sanchez hit hard and nicely
gloved on a hop by the shortstop
chisholm over to first base he got him
to end the inning
good play jazz chisholm ball hit to his
left a rocket
able to feel the tough in between bounce
and he makes the play to set down the
side oh jazz makes an unbelievable play
at short
what a play by jazz chisholm
so two out and here is
right-handed brian anderson here's a
pitch and this is hit well it's a high
drive to deep left center and it's going
to be up up and away in a home run for
brian anderson and a four to nothing
lead for the marlins for brian home run
number 11 rbi number 38 and the marlins
pick up an add-on run a big two-out hit
here in the fifth four to nothing miami
so two on and two out and that'll bring
up left-handed and corey dickerson
runners lead first and second pitch is
grounded weakly to second
wade will underhand the first and that
ends the inning no runs two hits
and
two left
john birdie two on two out oh two he
lays off a slide no he didn't he tried
to check his swing but he's rung up by
the home plate umpire and bertie can't
believe it he just spun around and he
looked back at cb buckner
and
i'll paraphrase you he said are you
kidding me
bernie can't believe it
chisholm had a booming double off the
center field wall that kind of
was right in the middle of that three
run second inning it's a fly ball out to
right center field hicks turns around
goodbye
that's a home run for jazz chisholm his
best day continues
and the marlins extend the lead to five
nothing
jazz has gone deep for the second time
as a big leaguer he's got a two hit
three rbi game
aaron judges walk twice into fly ball to
righto for one on the final day of the
regular season
and judge
out to left
sierra
makes the sliding play right along the
edge of the track
pitch hit on the ground in the shortstop
hole grab by torres a long throw
is
in time how do y'all like that a
beautiful play a backhand scoop
to retire aguilar
laboratories will be the battery well
this is out to
fairly deep left back is sierra making a
leaping play
a couple of great defensive plays from
sierra over the last few innings
sanchez hitless today hit into a double
play in the second grounded out in the
fourth good play by jazz chisholm
and in the seventh inning he struck out
and now sanchez with a fly ball out to
right field
it's gonna be brinson coming over to
make the play and for the final time in
the regular season and i hope there are
many more it's a marlins win their first
winning season since 2009.